[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
opinion editorial show reboot I'm Mike
McCarty I'm Jake and today we're going
to be talking about where Mass Effect
Andromeda or mass second general goes
next if you haven't watched it yet our
last episode of the show was about
science fiction storytelling and how
mass second drama that didn't really
deliver on its potential that we were
hoping but you can go watch that this is
our off week episode and we wanted to
kind of want to give Jake Chancellor his
opinion of the game and see our next
episode as usual so we're just gonna
jump right into Q&A we had a few
questions as always get YouTube comments
or tweets in they help us out a lot
piss people off of this episode I'd say
a little bit yeah definitely look at
some a good response to them yeah yeah
for sure
people were agreeing with them there are
people that like this game a lot I do
like parts of this game but I think
overall I was a little more negative on
it I think you're kind of split but yeah
so we'll get right into the questions we
have Jake read the second one but I'll
read the first one right now this is
from Ray Ray on YouTube and he said why
do you think story based games these
days lack really good story they have
time to make multiplayer or include
microtransactions in their games but
they can't be bothered to take the story
sorry to make a story in a game a
priority I don't necessarily agree with
that I think game stories are actually
getting better the more we play them or
the more developers make them I think
they're kind of realizing how you can
find your own stories and games which we
talked about in those Elba episode the
second episode of reboot but you know
games like the immersive Sims that
arcane is working on between pry up
coming probably hopefully I hope they do
it but Dishonored 2 Elder Scrolls games
Fallout games
I think they tell interesting stories
that can only be told in games and that
you're finding your own stories and
you're coming in with these water cooler
moments next days with your friends or
your co-workers and you're saying oh
this happened and it was awesome because
it meant something to me it might not
have meant the same thing to you but I
mean there are linear stories that
developers are telling me I know the
last MOS is one of your favorite games I
think that's one of the better stories
there is that's more cinematic yeah I
mean when I think of story in games like
it's kinda like movies right like some
some are going to be good some are going
to be bad and I think like what you were
saying that game developers are getting
figuring out how to tell good stories
her birth Mass Effect Andromeda I didn't
really want a story where you kind of
like find your own adventure or you
explore a world I wanted a tight story
not not tight in a sense as linear but
like a story that branches off different
actions consequences however what we got
the story was pretty weak which is not
what you want with a Bioware game that
is like that is the one thing not the
one thing but that is so important for a
Bioware experience to have that story
and when that's not there it just falls
so short of expectation just right away
uh yeah and I also wanted to give you a
chance and I kind of want to ask the
question where you think Mass Effect
could go next whether they do new
Andromeda's or whether they do prequel
like you had mentioned and like a lot of
people were hoping I don't know what do
you want to see I mean we ended the
episode on a hopeful note right like
hoping Bioware Montreal can pull it
together and maybe expand on the
potential that Andromeda had but I think
it kind of disappointed so where does it
go from here
yeah well the beautiful thing about the
Mass Effect series is they can literally
go anywhere there are millions of
stories to tell like you could
potentially tell like any kind of story
you want in that universe which i think
is awesome so I think there's definitely
room for improvement and room for
another story that's even better that's
hopefully a lot better in terms of where
they go I kind of don't really want to
see Andromeda again just because that
kind of left a bad taste in my mouth
however lean races and yeah yeah I think
I think they can do better in Andromeda
however what I'd really want to see and
I know this is a new people have been
wanting this for a while but I think
it'd be really cool to get a prologue
over the first contact war when you
first meet the turians and when you
first kind of figure out or you learned
there's this whole galactic civilization
just above earth yeah I mean once they
discover the mass relays that'd be a
really cool first contact story that we
haven't seen before rather than aliens
coming to Earth it would still be like
discovering there's not just one new
alien species but there's a ton of them
that have already bonded together in
this political environment but also like
have kind of learned to adapt to each
other yeah and kind of a Mass Effect one
you try to prove humanity's worse to an
extent but you've already established
that humanity's there
be really cool to just establish like
just try to prove yourself in general
yeah definitely the next question I will
lead to Jake it's more on the technical
side of things this one was from Jed
Barbour he said was the blue and red
paragon renegade lights uh uh lights on
your face on purpose for this video or
is that is that how your face always
looks and repair in real life yeah my
face is always lit on both sides from
one red one blue in my face in 3d no
actually with reboot we're trying to I
don't know just kind of play around with
different cinematic techniques for for
each episode and this one it just seemed
to make sense to do red blue Paragon
renegade we were trying to match an
image of the elusive man that we had
found online which we got kind of close
that we were missing some lighting in
your face but yeah each episode should
have its own unique style hopefully yeah
Lee Travis on Twitter also pointed out
that it kind of looks like the lighting
of Beyonce from yeah the VMAs yeah it's
what I think so yeah yeah and I hadn't
seen that so I could be compared to
worse people so I'm not sure your
techniques could be compared to worse
things than MTV I guess I don't know
okay alright alright last comment and as
good a time as any teaser next episode
this is from luis la pomme on YouTube
hey Mike could you please do persona 5
very succinct right to the point
yeah we're doing persona 5 the next
episode by the time this reboot 3.5 goes
up I will have been playing for who
knows how many hours uh it's my first
persona game so I'm also lending that
perspectives to the opinion Jake you
played four and you're looking forward
to five the time this publishes you
might have started playing five by now
but mainly how persona 5 you know we're
both big JRPG fans how persona 5
subverts JRPG tropes both in its combat
and his characters and its story and its
structure we're going to get into that
and take a deeper look at that and I'm
really excited because the more I play
this game the more surprising me not
just because my first persona game but
because of how they're setting up these
expectations of a JRPG and of this story
this high school story and how they're
actually toying with that and I really
like that some of my favorite aim to do
that so no 5 is on its way to being one
of my favorite games this year so far
yeah I'm excited to take a ticket
people look into that and play it yeah
as always I it helps so much when you
get these using questions in these
comments these you know Twitter mentions
we love that this is what this whole off
week episode is about and it helps us
keep doing the show which we love doing
and obviously Oh as always if you don't
subscribe to GameSpot please do so it'll
help us and all our co-workers keep
making these really fun shows and until
then we will see you next week when we
talk about persona 5 so yeah
[Music]